le texte que l'on dit vidé de sa
substance sera-t-il plus ou moins vert
qu'après son passage à l'assemblée en
tout cas 700 amendements étaient adoptés
par les sénateurs et le groupe
écologiste au sénat a tout de même parlé
d'avancées concrètes
on revient de loin avec cette loi climat
et résilience souvenez vous qu une
convention citoyenne avait été mise sur
pied à l'initiative d'emmanuel macron
elle avait élaboré 149 propositions pour
parvenir à respecter l'accord de paris
car c'était sa mission soit diminué de
55 % les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 et d'autres suggestions
pour mieux protéger la planète et bien
en avril en commission l'assemblée
nationale avait revu à la baisse toutes
les ambitions du texte et ils en avaient
retenu que quinze propositions
au point que les députés de l'opposition
avaient dénoncé un enfumage
traditionnellement le sénat étant à
droite et bien et donc plus conservateur
que l'assemblée et pourtant les
sénateurs porte quelques avancées sur ce
texte
appauvris comme la création d'un chèque
alimentaire le retour de la consigne un
prêt à taux zéro pour l'achat d'un
véhicule peu polluant la protection des
forêts des sols forestiers qui avait été
abandonné par l'assemblée nationale
la baisse de la tva sur les billets de
trains met au point de vue des reculs le
menu végétarien à l'école ne sera pas
généralisé seulement reconduit pendant
deux ans pour les collectivités qui le
souhaitent pas d'interdiction d'un
certain type de suremballage la lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols
reste très restreinte
il était question pour l'avion de
supprimer de nombreuses lignes
intérieures si une alternative rapide en
train exister et bien finalement seule
la ligne orly bordeaux va fermer donc la
loi climat et résidences ne promet pas
une révolution